[Music]
[Applause]
that's perfect
mama is on fire tonight
[Music]
I have the most fun when I come with you
mainly because of the pre-carpet
cocktails
oh my God I can't breathe so tonight I'm
wearing Gucci and I'm so excited to be
here
this dress is a very special dress it's
a 1992 full bride dress Chanel by Carl
if you feel like you've seen some looks
before you have co-chair Dua lipa's
corseted gown with pockets was
originally worn by Claudia schiffert as
for Margot Robbie I'm wearing Chanel
this is this um dress was worn by Cindy
Crawford in 1993.
my name is
[Music]
the same vintage Chanel gown in 2007 at
a photo spread with Carl and Nicole
Kidman's feathered frock was from her
2004 Chanel Number Five campaign
hi buddy Nicole you look amazing
Vivian Westwood designed my dress it's
an homage to Carl because he
photographed me when I was 13 and he put
a daisy crown on my head
Lily and I are paying homage to Carl so
we have Carl stenciled on our dresses
Jeremy Pope's 30-foot train had Carl's
face on it he needed five people to help
manage it while Janelle Monae honored
the fashion icon at changing on the
carpet from oversized outerwear to a
sheer dress with a sequined bikini and
speaking of Transformations that is
Jessica chastade in a platinum blonde
wig
Terry Washington's custom Michael Kors
took 1 000 hours to make by hand and had
135 000 recycled sequins and we got an
exclusive look at the making of new mom
Kiki Commerce Sergio Hudson gown with 12
000 pearls and crystals I mean he's just
eight weeks and he already changes every
day he was with us earlier getting ready
Rita Ora had the most iconic nails of
the night those foot long chains were a
take on a deconstructed Chanel necklace
working mama okay
of course sometimes one look just isn't
enough Olivia Wilde went from proper to
pushing the envelope in a see-through
net dress and black underwear Florence
Pugh with her newly shaved head and foot
tall headpiece changed into checkered
sequence well lizzo transforms it to a
blonde giving 70s Glam and J-Lo On The
Med stats she was Flawless in a Ralph
Lauren halter and leather Beret I wasn't
sure about the hat but now I'm kind of
feeling it but at the after party there
was this fashion faux pas check out the
tag still on her coat and that wasn't
the only wardrobe mishap this may be a
minor tear somewhere but I'm not going
to tell you where it's hard to sit in
traffic in a corset
good